my talk at the table is walgreens big
new step to get coveted vaccines to more
people it starts on friday
the pharmacy chain will expand
vaccinations in stores across 15 states
and major cities
now this is part of a president biden's
federal retail pharmacy program he's
been talking about it sends the vaccines
directly to dozens of national pharmacy
chains
and independent pharmacy networks so
people are
eligible rather can get vaccinated
locally first on cbs this morning we
like when we can say that
walgreens and uber think about this
combo are revealing a new partnership to
give people in underserved communities
free rides to vaccine appointments i
like this
their initiative will start in chicago
with plans to eventually expand to other
cities
rena shaw is walgreens group vice
president of pharmacy operations and
services
she joins us with uber ceo dara always
good to see you
khazra shahi to discuss this new
partnership
rina if you'll start us off because i
want to know how many
vaccines has walgreens administered and
how many more doses do you expect to
receive
gail first of all thank you so much for
having us we've been extremely humbled
to be able to provide
covid19 vaccinations to the long-term
care facility residents and staff
and we're looking forward to this
transition into the federal pharmacy
partnership
thus far we've been able to provide 2.3
million vaccinations
to individuals across the country and as
we get into this next
phase the federal pharmacy partnership
has been provided 1 million
vaccinations for this upcoming week and
will receive around 180 000 vaccinations
to help kick off this week yeah a lot of
people are saying here's my arm please
give me the shot
dara how is it going to work with uber
because we've heard stories of people
that can't get there to get the vaccine
how how are you all going to participate
with walgreens
and what happens if people get in the
car and they want to go to cvs dara
well we're we're going to encourage them
to go to walgreens in this case
you know it's our belief that
transportation should never be a barrier
for health care
especially as it relates to something as
important as vaccinations
this is part of a larger commitment with
uber to provide
10 million free rides to
areas and especially to underserved
communities so that
everyone can have access to this vital
vaccine
as it becomes more readily available and
we're just thrilled to work with
walgreens because walgreens has centers
essentially
all around the country we're going to
start in chicago but we're going to
expand into houston atlanta el paso as
well
and really provide uh this kind of
health care to
all communities regardless of especially
the ones that are hardest hit
by the virus hey dar it's time to cope
so on the
logistics and the practicalities of it
do people have to have uber on their
phone
uh do they have to already they need to
sign up a new is it required you have to
have a smartphone what are the
what are the like the logistics and
technicalities of it
so as you schedule an appointment
with walgreens you're going to get an
email from uber
so you can most people around have an
uber account if you don't have an uber
account you can create an uber account
and then you'll have access to the free
transportation to get to that walgreens
and uh
and get your vaccine rina each state has
different eligibility
eligibility requirements she's trying to
say so how is this going to work how can
people get their vaccine
by the end of this week you're right
every state has different requirements
on who's eligible
and so what we have is through our
scheduling process
we'll ensure that those individuals that
are eligible are the ones that are able
to schedule an appointment
and then as soon as they schedule an
appointment as dara mentioned then
they'll be notified
on what their options are and if they
want to utilize the uber
option to go ahead and be able to come
into our stores and get their
vaccination
dar i so love this partnership what
concerns do you have about pulling it
off because this is a big deal
it's so important and so badly needed
well i think the the biggest concern for
me
is actually education uh and when we
work with the cdc
one of the real barriers for underserved
communities to get
a vaccine is the trust is it safe
how effective is it so i think that we
not only have to provide
transportation and logistics but also
education
and we're partnering with the national
urban league with walgreens and other
partners
to make sure that the message gets out
there it's safe
it's effective and in this case
transportation is not going to get in
the way of your staying safe
yeah hey dar i've got a quick question
on the broader uh pandemic right now
because
uber is actually an interesting
indicator of where we are in the
pandemic
you said earlier in the year or may have
been late last year that ridership was
down
something like 70 percent during the
peak of the pandemic
what's it like now are people beginning
to get back out there
ridership is down now it's not quite as
bad as 70 percent
but it's still down quite significantly
in the u.s and europe as well
the asia pacific regions latin america
are coming back
faster uh but ridership is down
significantly and i think this is
all about all of us playing our part to
get back to some semblance of normal
in a safe way yeah absolutely rina
there's all sorts of reports of doses
going unused because they're not
properly stored
what are you all doing at walgreens to
make sure because this is also
a big deal on how this vaccine is stored
and kept safe
yeah the storage and handling is such a
critical component of making sure that
we're managing the vaccines and so all
of our stores are equipped
to support vaccinations may it be the
pfizer vaccine that requires the
ultra cold freezers or the dry ice or
the moderna vaccine that's available
so we do have end-to-end processes and
we do have policies in place and so that
not one dose gets wasted
and so the intent is is that we have
individuals that have signed up to get
vaccinations
in case there's a cancellation or any
other situation
that occurs we do reach out to other
patients that are able to get the
vaccine so we don't miss a single dose
and as dara mentioned it's so important
especially in these underserved
communities
that we're able to educate on the
importance of vaccine but then also
able to support the vaccinations as
those that are interested
and dara one final question for me about
covet protocols for
uber drivers because every time you get
in the car you are getting in the car
with a stranger
are the drivers regularly tested on a
regular basis
how does that work at your place the
protocols that we have in
uh place in every country depend on the
health authorities and right now we've
got a technology
with uber to make sure that your driver
is messed up
we actually have facial recognition
technology to make certain
and we have guidelines in place leave
your window open
these protocols have been safe
and are going to hopefully bridge us to
a place where truly the vaccinations
are when things are really going to open
up yeah when all else it fails just
stick your head out the window
i was going to say just roll it away
just like the dogs do it's very
effective
thank you guys we appreciate it guys
look this is a great partnership because
there are two things that prevent people
from getting vaccinations
they don't want it because they don't
know enough about it they don't trust it
or they can't get there and and this
program this new partnership
addresses both of those issues so thank
you very much we're glad to have it on
this morning
irina and dara thank you we appreciate
it